Imagine a nation, not, you know,
a young country, still finding
its feet, but a huge established
place built over generations
through subtle shifts, gradual
integration.
Then, almost overnight, it feels
like this colossal thing gets
thrown into this dizzying,
disorienting spin almost
capsizes our sources.
Today they use this really
powerful metaphor for that
feeling America as an aircraft
carrier.
Right.
Not a speedboat.
Exactly.
Not nimble, not designed for
quick turns.
It's this massive stable
platform.
Needs immense time and space
just to alter course.
A lot of inertia there.
Totally.
So the big question for our deep
dive today is how did a nation
known for this measured, almost
geological pace of cultural
change suddenly feel like it was
being spun around like, I don't
know, a racing cigarette boat?
That's a really potent way to
frame the perspective we're
digging into today.
Our deep dive is looking at what
one source labels America's
cultural reversion.
OK.
We're examining the rise of
what's called a reluctant
coalition that actively, you
know, pushed back against this
speed up in cultural shifts.
A.
Reluctant Coalition.
Interesting.
Yeah.
And our mission here is really
to dissect these sources,
understand the why and the how
behind this, a pretty profound
phenomenon.
It's definitely more than just
politics.
It's about a fundamental change
in how cultural change itself
was seen and handled in the US.
Absolutely.
So our mission is clear, unpack
how these American cultural
changes went from moving like,
like you said, tectonic plates
to becoming absolutely
turbocharged.
We'll explore who kicked off
this acceleration, what the
immediate and well the longer
term consequences have been, and
how it all seemed to lead to
what our sources are calling the
80% awakening.
OK, let's, let's get into this.
Let's do it.
So to really get the scale of
this shift, we kind of need to
understand America's historical
pace, right?
For centuries, American culture
evolved like those tectonic
plates, slowly, bit by bit,
almost impossible to see
day-to-day.
Almost invisible in the moment.
But, you know, over decades,
over generations, these shifts
created huge, undeniable
changes, really shake the
landscape of American identity.
And that analogy, it's not just
poetry, is it?
It really speaks to a very
organic process.
Assimilation, integration.
It happened slowly enough for
society to, well, adapt.
Adapt Exactly.
New influences got absorbed into
the existing structure without
demanding, you know, a total
erasure or replacement of what
was already there.
It suggests a kind of
foundational resilience, maybe,
where the core structure could
take on new elements without
just fracturing.
Precisely the material we looked
at describes America's melting
pot not as some high speed
blender, but as a slow simmer on
a back burner.
Right takes time.
Flavors mingled over generations
until eventually you couldn't
really tell the individual
ingredients apart from the whole
rich, complex thing.
That was how America
historically absorbed
difference.
It didn't demand conversion or
like strict adherence to one
single ideal.
It was more like a cultural
buffet.
Contributions were added to the
table.
Everyone could take what they
like.
Take what you want, leave the
rest kind of thing.
Yeah, nobody felt the need to,
you know, storm the kitchen and
demand a whole new menu.
It's a useful.
Think about it.
The Irish brought their pubs.
Their storytelling shaped
community life.
Italian immigrants, their food,
obviously, but also strong
family bonds.
Huge cultural impact.
The black community gave us
jazz, rock, hip hop, I mean
fundamentally transformed
American Music, global culture,
even Jewish immigrants.
Big influence on Hollywood
brought bagels into the
mainstream.
Yeah, iconic stuff.
And the crucial point, according
to this perspective, was that
these contributions got woven
into the fabric.
They enriched it, but they
didn't replace the existing
tapestry.
The center held in this view
because the changes happen at
that tectonic speed.
The pleats moved slowly enough
for people standing on them to
literally adjust their balance
and you can keep their footing.
Right.
And maybe you can reflect on
that, you know, how did that
older model foster a sense of
stability, maybe common ground
even with huge differences?
Yeah, you could have wildly
different backgrounds, beliefs,
but there was maybe an unspoken
agreement on some foundational
American identity, a shared
citizenship idea.
Which feels very different from
what many sources describe
experiencing more recently,
where differences feel less like
contributions to the whole and
more like competing claims for
what the whole even is.
That's a really sharp contrast.
And that brings us right to this
turbocharged turn.
Our sources seem to pinpoint
this dramatic speed up to
somewhere in the last 15 years.
15 years, give or take.
And the pace, as they describe
it, went from that slow,
deliberate tectonic movement to
something absolutely
turbocharged.
It's like flooring the
accelerator in a massive truck,
right?
Changes its whole nature.
And what's really critical to
grasp here, according to the
analysis, is that this
acceleration wasn't seen as
accidental.
It wasn't just happening, OK?
The analysis suggests it was
initiated pushed by a new
cultural elite, described as a
mostly educated coastal white
collar self anointed as the
moral vanguard.
Self anointed.
That's the term used, and from
their perspective, maybe they
saw an urgent need for rapid
systemic change.
Maybe they assume the nation
could adapt just as fast as
their own ideas were evolving.
And this is where that aircraft
carrier metaphor just clicks
right?
This elite, according to the
material we read, started
treating the American ship of
state not like the massive
carrier it is.
Needs miles to turn.
Requires miles of ocean just to
start turning, but instead like
a small agile Chris Craft
motorboat or even a racing
cigarette boat.
Nimble, Fast.
From their viewpoint, maybe from
the first class lounge as one
source put it, they thought they
could just bank the wheel hard
over change direction instantly.
Seems so simple from up there
perhaps?
Right, without fully accounting
for the sheer complexity, the
inertia of this vast, diverse
nation moving through time.
But that kind of speed has
consequences.
Doesn't immediate consequences,
and for many deeply unsettling
ones.
For the rest of America,
strapped into that carrier,
trying such a sharp, sudden
turn, well, it causes wings to
shear off and the whole thing.
Capsizes A catastrophic image.
This rapid change wasn't about
integration anymore.
It was plain and simple
whiplash.
Whiplash.
Yeah, that captures it.
And that kind of societal
whiplash, as history shows again
and again, it inevitably breeds
backlash.
Definitely, and maybe thinking
about recent cultural shifts,
you felt that whiplash yourself
or seen it.
Has the pace of change feel like
this unexpected, almost violent
lurch sometimes?
It's a feeling many people seem
to relate to.
And this rapid acceleration, it
created this profound disconnect
because for decades before there
was this implicit social
contract in America.
OK, what was that?
Where differences existed, sure,
but they were largely understood
as differences of degree, not of
kind.
A subtle but really powerful
understanding that allowed for
broad common ground.
Can you give an example?
Well, the sources offer some
stark ones.
For gay folks, the perception
often was same as us, just want
to marry their partner.
For black folks, maybe the
sentiment was same as us, just
with a different skin color.
For Asian immigrants, framed as
same as us, just with different
food at home.
The very goal in that equation
was generally narrow, a specific
custom, a preference.
But the common ground, that
fundamental sense of shared
identity, shared aspiration, it
felt wide.
So the underlying assumption was
that everyone wanted acceptance
into the broader American story.
That's what's fascinating, yeah,
the analysis suggests this
implicitly assumed a desire for
acceptance into the mainstream,
not a fundamental desire to
remake it.
OK, integration, not revolution.
Exactly.
The social contract seemed to
suggest that different groups
wanted to integrate, add their
flavor to the existing pot.
There was an expectation that
identities would be celebrated,
sure, but they wouldn't
fundamentally seek to overhaul
the core structure or values.
It was about expanding the US,
not replacing.
It But then something changed.
Our sources describe what they
call a revolution of
expectations.
A big shift.
Suddenly, that implicit deal
shifted dramatically.
The demand wasn't let us in
anymore.
It became hand over the keys.
Fundamentally different from
asking for a seat at the table
to demanding ownership of the
house.
Yeah, a different dynamic
entirely, moving from
assimilation or integration to
something far more radical,
according to this view.
And this is where that analogy
of a hostile takeover really
starts to bite.
How?
So.
Well, the analysis suggests that
every grievance, every
historical wrong, every buried
resentment wasn't just aired
anymore, which is part of the
older, slower process.
Instead, these grievances were
now quote weaponized against the
very culture that had made space
for the airing in the 1st place.
The melting pot that slows
simmer was abruptly dumped out
and replaced with an entirely
new recipe.
And often this came with this
unsettling declaration that the
old one had been poisoned all
along.
It felt like a stark,
confrontational break from the
past for many.
If you remember those corporate
dramas from the 80s, you know
the type.
Oh yeah, Wall Street, the
Raider.
Exactly.
The slick Wall Street Raider.
The corporate shark trying to
buy up some venerable old
company, not to nurture it, but
to chop it up, sell it for
parts.
Asset stripping.
Right.
And what was the reaction?
The employees, the lifers, the
rank and file.
They'd scramble right?
Try to buy shares, mount a
defense, anything to keep the
company whole.
Save their shared thing.
Protect what they built.
Well, the material we looked at
suggests that's exactly what
much of America felt like it was
doing in the last decade or so.
Like they were buying back stock
in their own culture before it
could be dismantled and sold off
under the banner of progress.
That's a powerful image, buying
back stock in your own culture.
And that very act of defense,
that sort of desperate attempt
to buy back stock, ironically
seems to have given rise to this
new, really unexpected
coalition.
And this coalition, this
defense, it wasn't about
achieving some kind of strict
ideological purity.
The sources are really clear on
this.
No.
What was it about then?
It seems it was born purely out
of necessity, a pragmatic coming
together of really disparate
groups who saw a shared threat,
even if their ultimate goals,
their visions for the future,
weren't perfectly aligned at
all.
Necessity.
OK.
You can see parallels
internationally.
Actually, the analysis points to
cases like the Afd in Germany
gaining huge traction and polls
even while being treated as
political lepers by the
established parties.
Strange bedfellows uniting
against a common enemy.
Exactly.
And in America, the analysis
suggests that's kind of what a
political movement like MAGA
became.
Whatever its original intent
was, it wasn't just traditional
Republicans, not just populist.
It became this sort of catch
basin for everyone who felt
pushed aside, ignored, or just
burned, earned by what they saw
as this dominant cultural elite.
So who is in this coalition?
It sounds diverse.
Hugely diverse.
Think about it.
Disaffected union members,
farmers struggling out in rural
areas, small town mayors trying
to hold on their community's
character, middle class
suburbanites feeling their
values were under siege.
Even old school Democrats who
just couldn't stomach what they
perceived as these new extreme
cultural purity tests.
The sources even mentioned some
successful tech figures who,
despite their own wealth, saw
the same elite preaching equity
while consolidating power and
money themselves.
Wow.
That really cuts across
traditional.
Lines It really does.
This broad coalition highlights
a deep shared dissatisfaction
that just transcends the usual
political labels.
It suggests that for a lot of
people, this perceived cultural
shift was so jarring, so
disruptive to their lives and
values, that it forged alliances
that was seemed impossible just
a few years before.
A testament to the unifying
power of shared discomfort,
maybe?
I think that's a good way to put
it.
And meanwhile, what our sources
describe as the woke liberal
monoculture seem to have quote a
hand on every lever right up
until Fey January 2025.
Every lever like what?
Federal agencies Big.
City Mayor's offices, blue state
governorships, the White House
itself, the media, universities,
even the HR departments of
almost every Fortune 500
company.
Wow, that's pervasive.
It felt pervasive, like it was
hard to operate in many
institutional spaces without
running into someone in charge
whose worldview seemed imported
wholesale from, you know,
diversity seminar.
And what's critical to
understand here is the
assumption that seemed to
underpin all this influence.
Because this elite hadn't really
faced any truly organized,
effective resistance, they,
perhaps quite logically from
their viewpoint, just assumed
none would ever materialize.
There was this sense that their
worldview wasn't just dominant,
it was unchallengeable.
The inevitable next step
couldn't be stopped.
Resistance did materialize,
didn't it it?
Absolutely did.
And as our sources highlight, it
didn't just come from the usual
suspects in political
opposition.
It came from what's described as
the 80% of America, the folks
who might not have time for
marches or memorizing the latest
acronyms, but who knew deep down
when the ground beneath them was
shifting too fast.
They.
Felt it in their daily lives,
communities, the institutions
they dealt with.
Exactly.
And this 80%, they didn't
necessarily agree on the
solutions, the analysis notes.
They barely agreed on diagnosis
sometimes.
But what they did agree on
unequivocally was that the pace
and the direction had to change.
It was this shared gut feeling
that things are moving too fast
and in a direction that felt
increasingly alienating,
unacceptable to them.
And when that coalition finally
formed, messy, imperfect, full
of internal contradictions, as
you said.
Yeah, definitely not monolithic.
It still proved powerful enough,
according to this view, to knock
the wheel out of the elite it's
hands.
A major shift in control.
And this wasn't about, you know,
some fantasy return to a
mythical past.
It wasn't a theocratic coup.
It was purely and simply a
collective.
No.
Just stop.
Yeah, from a country that felt
it was being treated like a
speedboat when it knew in its
bones it was an aircraft
carrier.
This 80% they didn't operate
with a central committee or a
manifesto or some single leader
in that top down Leninist way.
No.
They had something, as the
sources put it, more potent in a
moment like this.
Shared disgust.
That's a strong phrase.
It is.
And that shared disgust, the
analysis emphasizes, is a fast
bonding agent.
Like super glue.
Exactly.
You don't need to agree on every
detail of the blueprint for the
future if you can all agree that
the current structure is termite
ridden and swaying in the wind.
The immediate danger unites you.
That powerful, visceral
agreement on what was wrong was
enough.
Enough to bring together
strangers who wouldn't have
crossed the street to help each
other in the 90s to March in the
same direction in 2025, or at
least pull the same rope.
Pragmatic, reactive unity born
of necessity.
So this dynamic, the shared
opposition, it really shows how
a seemingly scattered group,
people with wildly different
backgrounds, different ideas,
even found common cause not in
some positive vision, but in
rejecting what they saw
happening to their culture.
That shared no became their
rallying cry.
A powerful unifying force, even
if negative.
And sometimes that rope pulling
that shared no, it showed up in
ways that seemed almost absurd
on the surface.
Like what?
Consider what the sources
described as a crystallizing
moment.
The infamous DOJ sandwich
thrower.
The sandwich thrower I remember
reading about.
That sounds like satire.
It really does.
DOJ attorney hurls Subway
sandwich, A federal officer
shouts fascist.
But in our world, which is so
hyper symbolic, moments like
that become incredibly
revealing.
It's more than just a weird
anecdote, isn't it?
The analysis frames it as
shorthand for a deeper rot.
Deeper rot?
How so?
Well, think about it.
This wasn't some drunk kid at a
protest.
This was an officer of the
court, someone whose salary
comes from the federal treasury,
choosing to express disagreement
by weaponizing their lunch.
Japanizing lunch, Yeah.
It's petty, sure, but it's also
revealing.
It exposes this mindset where
maybe the people in charge of
enforcing rules see themselves
as morally above them.
And that's the kind of incident
that, for a lot of people, turns
suspicion into conviction.
Exactly.
You hear terms like deep state
often dismissed as just a fringe
conspiracy thing.
But then you see an official
from a government institution
acting in a way that feels so
unprofessional, so ideologically
driven, and suddenly that
paranoia about institutional
capture stops being paranoia and
starts feeling like a working
hypothesis makes an abstract
worry feel very real.
And it wasn't just this one
incident, Was it this coalition?
The sources say they didn't need
PowerPoints or white papers to
bond over their frustration.
No, they had something.
Else they had this growing reel
of these you can't make this up
moments, each one like a small
tremor that added together, made
it feel like the ground itself
was shifting.
Humiliation is key.
Yeah, imagine a City Council
voting to remove math
requirements not for educational
reasons, but because equity.
Or a school board arguing that
merit based admissions are
inherently racist.
Controversial stuff.
Or a major companies HR
department sending out a like 37
point checklist on pronoun
etiquette with mandatory
training while at the same time
announcing layoffs for 12% of
the workforce.
The juxtaposition is jarring.
Totally.
Each moment on its own might
seem local, maybe even just
silly.
But piling them up built this
powerful narrative of
disconnect, of overreach.
Which raises a really important
question, How do these seemingly
scattered incidents actually
come together to form a powerful
collective feeling, one that can
drive real change?
Well, in political science they
often talk about focusing
events.
Focusing events.
Yeah, Moments that aren't just
news items.
They're powerful symbols that
crystallize, that diffuse
widespread frustration into
targeted, unified action.
They make a perceived problem
tangible, urgent, undeniable.
OK, I think I get that.
Like a lightning rod.
Sort of culturally, our sources
offer this great analogy.
It's it's like that one song at
a wedding reception that gets
everyone on the dance floor.
Yeah, OK.
Doesn't matter if Uncle Ted
hates disco and your college
roommate only likes heavy metal.
Everybody knows the chorus.
Everybody moves together for
three minutes.
These incidents provide that
common chorus that beat everyone
recognizes.
Allows disparate people to see
their shared frustration makes
sense.
And historically, America's seen
similar patterns, right?
Think about the Jack Soni revolt
against the Adams Clay elite
back in the 1820s.
OK, Yeah.
Populist uprising.
Against what was seen as an
entrenched out of touch
establishment.
Or Fast forward to the 1980's,
the rise of the Reagan
Democrats.
Blue collar union guys voting
Republican.
Exactly.
Traditionally, Democratic voters
pulling the lever for Reagan, a
former actor, because the left
of their time seemed to them
captured by urban intellectuals
pushing a cultural agenda they
just didn't recognize anymore.
So it wasn't just about policy
differences.
These movements, the sources
argue, don't follow party lines
as much as they follow gut
lines.
People feel the culture veering
away in a direction that feels
alien, maybe threatening, and
they react.
They slam the wheel the other
way.
Not necessarily towards
something perfectly coherent.
But definitely away from
something they find intolerable.
It shows this deep pattern,
cultural currents driving big
change, not just political
disagreements.
Right now, here's the
interesting part.
The inherent paradox, maybe the
promise to of this 80%
coalition.
It's described as being almost
entirely negative space.
Negative space, yeah.
It exists.
It gets its power because of
what it rejects, not because of
what it builds.
It's not unified by some
detailed blueprint for the
future, it's unified by a shared
no to how things are.
Which sounds like a weakness,
but you're saying it has
advantages.
Exactly because it's defined by
rejection, it becomes incredibly
fluid, adaptable and hard to
destroy.
How so?
It can shift focus as the
perceived threat changes.
It doesn't have this rigid dogma
you can easily pick apart or
defeat.
It's lack of a fixed positive
identity makes it kind of
elusive, resilient.
Right to its Achilles heel,
doesn't it?
It does the key weakness.
Once the common enemy is gone,
the glue can melt overnight.
The thing that unites them,
shared opposition, disappears.
And then what?
Then the.
Disparate factions might just
reassert their own, often
conflicting priorities.
So this movement kind of
requires a foil then?
That's what the analysis
suggests.
Whether it's a specific
political figure or a broader
concept like woke, the Coalition
needs that external adversary to
stop it from splintering into
its natural factions.
And those factions could be
quite different.
Absolutely.
Without that common enemy, you
immediately see the potential
splits.
You've got libertarians wanting
government off their back
entirely.
Clashing with conservatives who
might want government enforcing
certain morals.
Right or economic populace
wanting government in the
boardroom protecting workers.
Contrasting with anti globalists
who want it off the world stage
altogether.
These are fundamentally
different views, held together
mostly by that shared opponent.
Which brings up this serious
risk of, well, just fading away.
Ephemerality.
Exactly.
The danger is this powerful
movement becomes it's just
another Tea Party burns
incredibly bright for a while.
And burns out, leaving the
establishment to quietly retake
control.
And the stakes here, the sources
really emphasizes they're not
just electoral, they're
cultural.
Because once a coalition like
this falls apart, it's way, way
harder to rebuild it a second
time.
The momentum is lost, yeah.
Right, so the lesson for anyone
navigating these cultural shifts
seems stark.
Speed kills, but so does
complacency.
You can't just win and assume
it's over.
The difficult balancing.
Act And that's pretty much where
America finds itself right now,
doesn't it?
Sitting on this vast, creaking
carrier, navigating these seas
turned by speedboats, darting
around its hull and constantly
arguing about who should be on
the bridge and whether the
current course leads to
salvation or, you know,
disaster.
It's a moment of profound
uncertainty, even with a big
shift in who's holding the
wheel.
But there is this partial
victory, right?
That's crucial to acknowledge.
For the first time in decades, a
majority of the passengers on
that carrier have at least
agreed that the wheel shouldn't
be left in the same hands as
before.
That consensus is significant.
They might not agree on where to
steer, they might not have a
unified destination, but they
are pretty sure they know who
not to trust with the rudder.
That alone is a huge shift.
Absolutely.
But the old elite hasn't
vanished.
The analysis is very clear about
that.
They've just been knocked below
decks, so to speak.
OK, so they lost the helm,
they're not steering anymore,
but they still have influence.
Powerful, pervasive influence.
They still run the ship's
intercom.
The ship's intercom explain
that.
Think about it.
They can't direct the vessel,
maybe, but they can still
broadcast messages to every
single passenger on board.
They can still shape perception.
OK, Media, cultural
institutions.
Exactly.
Cable news, legacy papers, the
prestige magazines.
They are, the analysis argues,
all still staffed and edited by
the same class who drove the
cigarette boat into the side of
the carrier.
The ones who caused the whiplash
in the 1st place and.
Now, maybe because they're
unburdened by the practicalities
of actually governing, dealing
with budgets, votes, laws.
Right.
They don't have to deliver.
They are, in a way, broadcasting
from the bilge, narrating every
single jolt and lurch, every
minor course correction as
immediate proof that the new
hands of the wheel are drunk,
blind, or both.
Designing the narrative to sow
doubt undermine confidence.
It's almost more potent than
when they were in power.
In some ways.
Before, their narratives had to
grapple with the constraints of
reality, of governing.
Now it could be pure agitprop.
They.
Don't have to steer, they just
have to scream iceberg every 30
seconds.
Exactly.
So doubt, so panic among the
passengers and this diverse
coalition that took the wheel,
It isn't immune to that.
A few well placed panic stories.
A scandal here, a gaffe there.
You can see the edges fray.
And that's the paradox, isn't
it?
Winning without really replacing
the underlying power structures.
Precisely the institutions that
this coalition may be ejected
from direct political power
still control the framing of
reality.
They can't turn the carrier like
they used to.
But they can convince enough
passengers that it's listing
that it's off course, even if
it's not.
And in politics, as the analysis
reminds us, perception is half
the voyage.
Perception becomes reality.
In many ways, yes.
And this isn't just an American
thing either, is it?
Our sources stress that the same
stories playing out in miniature
all over the world.
It's not an isolated domestic
fight, it's part of a bigger
global current.
Look at Europe, for example.
You had those farmer protests in
the Netherlands, blocking
highways, angry about climate
mandates that felt totally
disconnected from their lives.
Major disruptions.
French workers out in force
protesting pension reform, huge
resistance to top down
directives and then Germany's
Afd as you mentioned, out
pulling every party while being
treated as political lepers by
the establishment.
And further afield you see Latin
American populists displacing
that old neoliberal order while
the media narrative often paints
every single one as a proto
dictator.
The language, the reaction, it's
strikingly similar everywhere.
The common thread seems clear.
It's the same fight, different
accents, ordinary people saying
slow down, elites calling it
heresy.
It's this widespread pushback
against perceived overreach
against rapid imposed change.
And the foreign policy class,
well, they naturally hate this.
Understandably, from their
perspective, their whole
currency is consensus, right?
And consensus is way easier when
the domestic herd moves is 1
when there's a predictable
unified front at home.
They prefer stability above.
All their preference, clearly,
would be for America to stay a
stable, docile client of its own
bureaucracy, a steady hand
abroad, A predictable market at
home.
Predictability is key.
But a rest of 80%?
Absolute nightmare fuel.
For them, it means unpredictable
elections.
Leaders who might openly
question alliances like NATO.
Trade deals suddenly on the
chopping block.
Foreign capitals no longer able
to count on Washington's words,
surviving the next cycle.
Introduces chaos unreliability
upends their whole model.
Exactly.
So the global order isn't just
being shaken by, say, China or
Russia anymore.
It's being deeply rattled by
American domestic politics,
becoming less polite, less
managerial and more populist.
And that fuels the same elite
panic we see in the domestic
culture wars, because if they
can't control the narrative at
home.
They certainly can't guarantee
the narrative abroad.
It's all connected.
And here's the tricky bit, the
uncomfortable truth the old
guard maybe can't say out loud.
What's that?
The carrier will still sail even
without them on the bridge.
It keeps moving.
The seas might be rougher, the
turns wider, sure, but the ship
moves, and if it moves in a
direction the passengers
actually voted for, a course
correction reflecting the
majority will while it might
start feeling less like chaos
and more like genuine ownership
for people.
And that, the sources argue, is
the real long term threat for
the old elite.
Not authoritarianism
necessarily, but genuine popular
autonomy.
That really broadens the
perspective, doesn't it?
Shows how these internal
cultural fights about who holds
the rudder, how fast the ship
turns, ripple out globally,
reshaping international
relations in huge ways.
It's not just about American
identity, it's about America's
place in the world.
So the danger for this coalition
now is kind of the flip side of
its strength.
Right.
Without that organizing villain,
without the constant emergency
that forged their unity, it
could very well dissolve into
bickering factions long before
it consolidated real cultural
control.
That shared disgust needs a
target.
The glue melts without an enemy.
And that's a critical
distinction because winning an
election, taking the helm, is
just not the same as winning the
narrative.
And winning the narratives.
Is not the same as shaping the
next generation's default
assumptions.
What people just take for
granted is normal.
And the old elite understood
that perfectly.
That's how they captured so many
institutions over decades,
right?
Embedded their worldview deep in
the cultural fabric.
So the analysis suggests the
real battle isn't just storming
the bridge, it's deciding what
to do once you're there.
The governing part, yeah.
The cigarette boat crowd, the
old elite.
They still have the charts, the
radios, the loud speakers, and
this stubborn belief they're the
rightful captains.
If the 80% can't figure out how
to rewrite the map and rewire
the comms, the.
Wheel will almost inevitably
slip right back into familiar
hands.
Inertia takes over.
So this cultural reversion we're
seeing, it's not a done deal,
it's provisional.
The sources call it a mutiny,
not yet a transfer of command,
right?
And history tells us, in
mutinies, the hardest part isn't
seizing control, it's keeping it
when the adrenaline fades.
That initial surge of anger?
Shared purpose.
It's powerful but lasting change
that takes enduring commitment.
And that's the part maybe nobody
in the coalition wants to think
about.
Insurance revolt or exciting
dramatic governing building
culture often just exhausting.
Yeah, the 80% might have dragged
the wheel away, but holding it
steady through storms, currents,
even sabotage, that's a totally
different skill set.
And without a clear plan for
succession, for their own kind
of cultural capture, they risk
becoming just a one generation
flare in the dark, bright, brief
and gone.
Which brings up a crucial
insight.
Cultural power doesn't vanish,
it seeps.
Seeps.
Yeah, it seeps back through the
cracks you forgot to seal.
Think about this.
Seemingly boring institutions
that form the ballast of the
ship.
Like what?
School boards, zoning
commissions, editorial boards
for local papers, Professional
licensing agencies?
The places that if ignored, just
refill with the same kind of
people you just threw out.
Because those are the people who
consistently show up to every
meeting, every hearing, every
working group.
Most people never even hear
about.
Exactly.
The mutiny can end with the old
crew back in charge without a
shot fired, just through this
cultural entropy, the slow creep
back.
Which is why the next phase for
this movement can't simply be
anti woke or anti anything
really.
Resistance movements defined
only by opposition tend to burn
hot then cold, the reactive not
generative.
To truly lock in their gains,
the people who won the bridge
have to start acting like they
plan to hold it for the long.
Haul, and that means put rolling
up their sleeves.
Investing in slow, boring,
unglamorous work culture doesn't
flip like a switch.
It turns at the speed of habit.
Habit, the fabric of daily life.
And a habit gets built in
specific tangible places.
Classrooms, hiring committees,
curriculum drafts, shaping what
kids learn, zoning decisions,
shaping communities, local
programming budgets, deciding
what culture gets made and seen.
So.
Changing the flag on the mast is
easy.
Relatively easy, yeah.
Symbolic.
But if the ship's log, the
compass, and the maps all come
from the old officers, the
course will bend back without
anyone noticing until landfall.
It has to be deep structural
change, not just symbols.
There's also this challenge of
translation, isn't there?
Definitely.
The 80% speaks in this language
of plain frustration.
Slow down, leave me alone, stop
breaking things that work.
Gut feelings, understandable
sentiments.
But the institutions they've
wrestled control of, even
briefly.
They speak a totally different
language.
Policy memos, regulations,
appropriations, bureaucracies,
essentially.
And turning that raw frustration
into durable rules, lasting
structures.
It requires people fluent in
both dialects, which is a rare
skill.
Without it, this reversion risks
being just a series of loud,
satisfying vetoes with no
enduring architecture beneath
them.
All reaction, no construction.
And here the aircraft carrier
analogy comes full circle again.
How so?
The old Elite tried to spin it
like a cigarette boat snapped
the mast.
The 80% wrestled the wheel away
to stop it capsizing.
But now they face the opposite
problem.
An aircraft carrier that won't
turn unless you keep steady,
consistent pressure on the helm
for months, years even.
Which in politics feels like
forever, but in cultural change,
it's barely a blank.
Exactly.
So the question is, can this
coalition resist that natural
human urge to declare victory
and wander off the deck before
the turn is complete?
If they can, well, the story
risks ending like too many
others in American history, with
the same class of people back in
charge, armed with fresh moral
authority from having survived
the mutiny, and an even deeper
conviction that the passengers
just can't be trusted to steer.
But if they can succeed.
Then we might be seeing not just
a course correction, but the
slow establishment of a new
cultural default, one less
obsessed with speed, more
suspicious of fads rooted in
that kind of incrementalism
that, ironically, used to be
America's unspoken civic
religion.
There's also an opportunity in
the very looseness of this
coalition, right?
You mentioned that.
Yeah, because it doesn't have a
rigid dogma.
It can adapt.
It can absorb people who would
never sign on to a strict
ideological platform.
That breath, if managed right,
can be a huge strength.
So if it learns to turn that
adaptability toward building
something new.
Instead of just resisting, yeah,
yeah, it could potentially
solidify a new Cultural Center
that resists the pendulum swing
for decades.
But that would mean accepting
internal disagreement.
Accepting it is not a threat,
but a feature.
It's the price you pay for
having such broad, diverse
support.
You can't have a huge tent and
demand everyone inside things
exactly alike.
This is a crucial lesson from
the old elite, isn't it?
They mastered permanence.
They absolutely did.
They weren't just about winning
elections.
They painstakingly seeded their
worldview into every institution
that touches daily life.
Schools, entertainment,
professional accreditation,
newsrooms, even the language of
HR and advertising.
Right, So their values, their
default assumptions, could
survive political losses because
the cultural tide always subtly
tilted back their way.
That's the difference between a
temporary surge and a lasting
shift.
And the 80%, the sources say,
has to understand it too, or
this whole powerful moment just
becomes a historical curiosity,
a blip.
So the task ahead is just
enormous.
It's about building alternative
institutions that can actually
outlast election cycles.
Creating parallel cultural
products, movies, books, music
that aren't just anti woke
reactions but are actually
compelling, inspiring, resonate
with people on their own terms.
And training a whole generation
to defend the principles that
brought them here, but without
needing an existential enemy
constantly rallying them.
This is infrastructure, not just
insurgency.
Exactly.
And right now the analysis
suggests too many in the 80% are
still acting like insurgents.
Reactive, maybe self satisfied
with their winds, more
interested in defeating the
opponent than defining and
building their own path forward.
But there is hope on the open
sea.
There is.
The wheel is in unfamiliar
hands, yes, but those hands
might discover they can navigate
without the old maps.
That's the potential.
Here and the ultimate test is.
Will the Coalition still show up
for the boring stuff?
School budgets?
State House committee hearings?
Will it recruit candidates for
library boards?
Accrediting bodies?
The real ballast will train a
generation not just to resist,
but to create new stories,
ritual, civic habits that future
Americans just take for granted
as the new normal.
Because permanence isn't just
about who holds power.
It's about what becomes default,
what simply is.
The old elite knew that.
If the 80% doesn't learn that
lesson, this moment shrinks to a
brief, noisy pause before the
familiar programming resume.
So the long game is keep at it.
Keep the wheel, keep the
heading, keep the habit of
steering.
Do that long enough for a new
Cultural Center to harden, for
new defaults to emerge.
Then the old guards return isn't
just delayed.
It's impossible without the kind
of generational project they
themselves once undertook.
The mutiny becomes a true change
of course, so deep it doesn't
even feel like steering anymore.
That's the potential long term
outcome, yeah.
So as we close out this deep
dive, we've really journeyed
through how American cultural
change went from that slow
organic pace to these rapid
imposed shifts, sparking this
profound mutiny by the 80%.
And we understand, I think, that
the ship is still very much in
open water.
The seas are undeniably choppy.
The future isn't written yet
there.
The old crew hasn't stopped
whispering through the bulkheads
trying to sew that doubt and
division.
And frankly, the new crew hasn't
proven it can navigate without
running aground.
The outcome is still very much
in flux.
But for the first time in a
generation, the wheel isn't
bolted into the same hands, and
that alone, that fact,
profoundly changes the
possibilities of where this
vessel might actually go.
It opens up the map.
It does.
But the real question, the one
we want to leave you, the
listener, to ponder is is this
the start of a deep, permanent
shift in America's cultural
direction, or is it merely
another flare in the dark?
A bright flash, then gone.
Yeah, a bright, intense flash
illuminating things for a
moment, only to fade, leaving
the path uncertain again.
What will you observe in the
coming years as signs pointing
one way or the other?
Keep watching, keep thinking,
and keep digging.